porns produced in the UK is going to be
censored that's right according to a
2003 amendment to the Communications Act
porn that is actually made in the UK is
going to be censored a lot of different
acts that you probably like you pervert
and we've got a list of them right here
spanking caning what's Kayne and Kim I
don't know all right we'll get to that
in a minute
Luis do caning would you like the caning
it's not hitting with a cane hitting
with a cane that's right aggressive
whipping is with the whip if you would
put him with a cane to be caning yeah I
think painting is with the cane whipping
is with the whip there you go what a
stick that's sticking that's aggressive
stick I get it I get it okay penetration
by any object quote associated with
violence we'll get more to that one I
think that's kinda interesting physical
or verbal abuse regardless of if it's
consensual euro
Lyonya which is more commonly known as
water sports female ejaculation
strangulation facesitting I want to talk
about that one too and fisting okay so
just to be very clear they're banning
this to be produced in the UK so if you
live in the UK fear not you can still
get it from Germany in the US and Japan
and wherever else you're getting your
porn from but I do think this is kind of
interesting because in we live in a
world where there are no borders anymore
right everyone gets everything online
anyway so what is the UK government
actually trying to accomplish here
except they're just gonna hurt their own
economy they're their own porn I feel
like I want to hear someone say sporting
with a British accent so that's really
cutting into that for me Kim can you do
squirting with the you can't do that no
no no no now can you squirt right now I
mean can you say squirting with the
British accent alright so we're fine so
we're good yeah I was worried for a
minute there but I think we're okay
but really doesn't this seem odd that
they would outlaw the act being done in
their country but they're not gonna stop
people from watching this stuff so what
are they really trying to accomplish see
I thought maybe violence but a lot of
this is really arbitrary I mean
facesitting is is that violent they're
arguing that you could actually do some
serious damage that way and I'm sure
someone has died from face it a you
could crush someone yeah if someone has
died from fisting perhaps yeah really
aggressive just
vaginal punching I don't know but also
things like I mean the verbal stuff I
mean like you know I guess you could die
of humiliation yeah that's strange it
says regardless if if it's consensual
right right so these are you protecting
with this yeah I don't understand what's
going on here right so the final three
those last three can we throw the list
up for just a second I want to be very
clear on this so we know we're talking
about the last three strangulation so
that's obviously choking someone
facesitting as Lewis points out and
fisting all fall under the BB C f/c view
of potentially life-endangering so I
think that's something I I have a
problem with the female ejaculation part
that seems especially wrong to me that
seems you're not into that it's not like
you can I mean some people can control
that sure yeah but if it happens it
happens
yeah I don't want some porn star who
happens to be a little bit more
squirty okay to be to be banned from
doing porn in the UK right so it's our
fault
so this is squirt discrimination if it
is guys squirt all the time there's a
problem I don't see that on this list
it feels very sexist to me yeah why
really though when you think about the
amount of porn that's out there that
everyone knows about you can get any
kind of porn that you want and all that
what do you think the UK is really
trying to do like what are they really
saying to their people here what is it
that they're getting that here are they
trying to be prude are they trying to be
as they are they having their like
Christian conservative moment that
stereotype of typical British gentleman
going like oh you know so this is has to
do with their t unseemly things yeah
these are things that like I mean I also
have a problem with the obvious OCA with
violence because if you don't want to
like use a gun on someone in a sexually
that's fine but you could hurt someone
with a dildo you know what I mean I just
don't
spirals it's dangerous to kind of start
censoring these things because suddenly
everything's a weapon that's right
people you can hurt someone with the
dildos